ich freue mich dass sie dabei sind
herzlich willkommen hier bei halle
deutschland am mittwoch unter starten
wir wie jeden tag zurzeit mit einem
corona kompakt und da haben wir auch
wieder eine expertin hier im studio
heute ist es der virologe professor bodo
plachta zunächst gucken wir aber erstmal
auf die neuesten entwicklungen des tages
und inzwischen auch die einsatzkräfte
vor ganz neuen herausforderungen stehen
die korona pandemie stellt mittlerweile
auch rettungskräfte vor probleme wie bei
diesem brand gestern abend in lünen bei
dortmund hier brennt ein
mehrfamilienhaus die feuerwehr muss 14
menschen über eine drehleiter retten
doch während des einsatzes stellt sich
heraus eine gerettete familie stand
unter corona quarantäne
dass wir entsprechend
sachen dann entsprechend abarbeiten
die betroffene familie muss abseits der
anderen hausbewohner warten für den
restlichen einsatz tragen die retter
mundschutz und die dienstkleidung des
feuerwehrmanns aus dem drehleiterwagen
wird vorsichtshalber in einer tüte
verstaut herausforderungen wie diese
könnten sich demnächst häufen denn die
aktuellen zahlen zur nachgewiesenen
corona infektionen sind
besorgniserregend heute hat deutschland
die zehntausender marke geknackt 10.000
82 infizierte und 26 tote tendenz
steigend gerade jetzt bewegen bilder wie
diese im internet nachbarn einer
bamberger reihenhaussiedlung die von
ihren balkonen aus gemeinsam bella ciao
singen
[Musik]
als zeichen der solidarität mit
besonders von corona betroffenen
gebieten wie italien und auch dieser
allabendliche applaus geht momentan um
die welt jeden abend klatschen menschen
am offenen fenster um helfern und
pflegekräften in der aktuellen krise
ihre wertschätzung zu zeigen
entstanden ist die idee in italien auch
immer mehr deutsche städte ziehen mit
wie hier in köln stehen die menschen
punkt 21 uhr am offenen fenster und
klatschen ein solidarisches zeichen in
der krise dramatisch hingegen ist immer
noch die situation an der deutsch
polnischen grenze in richtung polen bei
polnische staatsbürger die zurück in
ihre heimat wollen erst auf fieber
kontrolliert werden staut es sich massiv
vom tresen schon aus 47 kilometer stau
ist und die leute weinen und kollabieren
zusammen dabei ihnen weil die menschen
stehen seit 20 oder länger im stau also
dass und das bewegt sich kein bisschen
menschen die aus polen herausfahren
bringen wasser und lebensmittel für die
wartenden und legen sie an der
leitplanke ab die hilfsbereitschaft ist
groß
hier hofft jeder dass sich die lage
nicht nur an den grenzen möglichst
schnell wieder entspannt
ja das hoffen wir alle und
wahrscheinlich auch sie professor dr
bodo platter virologe am uniklinikum
mainz herzlich willkommen schön dass sie
bei uns in den armen
aber das robert-koch-institut sie haben
es gehört hat heute morgen gesagt wir
sind am anfang einer epidemie die noch
viele wochen und monate unterwegs sein
wird also das macht er weniger hoffnung
auf eine schnelle trendwende oder wie
sehen sie das
na gut das ist im prinzip schon lang
eigentlich bekannt dass es sicherlich
sich hinziehen wird
die frage ist nur wie stark das dann uns
beeinträchtigen wird natürlich besteht
irgendwo die hoffnung dass man das über
die zeit hinweg besser in den griff
kriegt das kann man auch aus anderen
ländern lernen die es auch geschafft
haben mit solchen maßnahmen und dann
wird man sehen ob man nicht dann
nach wenigen wochen vielleicht auch die
maßnahmen entsprechend wieder etwas
lockern kann
das heißt also neuer neue umschreibung
für das was eigentlich schon bekannt ist
so kann man das eigentlich aussehen ja
im prinzip wider erwarten wir das schon
seit wochen eigentlich dass die zahlen
nach oben gehen dass tritt jetzt ein
tatsächlich und wer wird dann
weitersehen müssen in ein bis zwei
wochen ob diese maßnahmen die wir jetzt
ergreifen dann auch wirklich wirken
wir schauen mal drauf und wir schauen
auch mit auf weitere fragen die unsere
zuschauer haben die konnten sie uns
natürlich mailen und sie sind weiter her
für uns im studio gleich und reden
weiter aber erst mal noch ein ganz
anderes thema vielen dank schon mal für
den moment ja fragen die entstehen eben
aber auch dadurch dass sich immer mehr
falsche nachrichten und meldungen
verbreiten gerade im internet nimmt über
die sozialen medien da wird es eine
menge geteilt was ja äußerst fragwürdig
ist auch kommen da erstaunlich viele
angebliche experten zu wort doch wie
kann man corona fake news von
warnmeldungen unterscheiden
immer mehr nachrichten über das corona
virus prasseln auf die menschen ein
immer mehr sinke unruhig wissen nicht
mehr was richtig oder falsch ist auch
[Musik]
dieses junge paar bleibt vorsorglich zu
hause während sie noch arbeitet kuriert
er sich aus hoffentlich nur eine
erkältung in einer nachricht die in den
sozialen medien kursiert soll angeblich
schon ein ganz einfaches mittel helfen
das virus zu bekämpfen wasser
ein schluck alle 15 minuten soll das
virus in den magen befördern und damit
unschädlich machen
in manchen versionen des kettenbrief es
wird zwar die stanford university als
quelle genannt
doch diese hat diesen hinweis nie
veröffentlicht
[Musik]
zwar ist es bei einer infektion generell
ratsam viel zu trinken denn tatsächlich
werden dadurch keime und viren im rachen
zum teil ausgespült doch der mund ist
nicht das einzige einfallstor für die
viren sie können ebenso über nase oder
augen in den körper gelangen
regelmäßiges wassertrinken ist zwar
gesund gegen eine infektion mit dem
neuen virus hilft es jedoch nicht
soziale medien sind also keine
verlässliche quelle
aber was ist mit einer empfehlung die
auf seriös wirkenden webseiten zb von
ärzten zu finden ist
vitamin d das sonnen vitamin soll einer
infektion mit dem corona virus vorbeugen
in dem zusammenhang wird unter anderem
die whu die weltgesundheitsorganisation
zitiert kann uns vitamin d tatsächlich
schützen
was stimmt vitamin d trägt zur normalen
funktion des immunsystems bei der
menschliche körper bildet das vitamin
bei sonneneinstrahlung bei einem akuten
mangel kann man zwar mit vitamin d
präparaten gegen steuern
doch es gibt keine empfehlung der whu
zur prophylaktischen einnahme gegen das
aktuelle corona virus und konkrete
studien die eine wirksamkeit von
vitaminen zur vorbeugung der korona
infektion belegen gibt es ebenfalls
nicht
ein spaziergang in der sonne können
dennoch nicht schaden oder oberflächen
sind doch rheins tieren schleudern
viren können darauf doch stundenlang
angeblich sogar bis zu drei tage
überleben
in einem labortest wurde tatsächlich
gezeigt dass neue corona virus bleibt
auf kunststoff und edelstahl bis zu 72
stunden lang infektiös die zahl der
viren nahm zwar drastisch ab aber es
reichte noch um eine zellkultur zu
infizieren
auch diese geringe viren anzahl jedoch
auch genügt um einen menschen zu
infizieren lässt sich anhand dieser
studie jedoch nicht sagen
fakt von fake zu unterscheiden bleibt in
der flut von nachrichten schwierig wie
geht man am besten damit um
statt auf dubiose chat nachrichten oder
hörensagen zu vertrauen sollte man sich
bei seriösen medien und einrichtungen
informieren wie auf den seiten des
robert koch instituts oder der
bundesministerien
nur hier kann man sich sicher sein
die meldungen wurden geprüft und gerade
in zeiten von corona ist das umso
wichtiger denn fragen gibt es eine menge
und täglich neu allein die sache mit der
ansteckung kann das virus auch über die
türklinke oder den griff am
einkaufswagen zb weitergegeben werden
ein paar dinge davon hatten wir schon
gerade aber was ist mit anderen
oberflächen ob im öffentlichen raum oder
in den eigenen vier wänden ständig
berühren wir oberflächen die andere
schon vorher berührt haben in busse oder
bahnen oder auch im supermarkt kennt man
die anderen menschen meist nicht die
frage ob coronaviren über oberflächen
verteilt werden können ist daher
zunächst eine ganz generell
es gibt erste studien die natürlich im
labor gemacht werden und da sieht es so
aus als ob metalloberflächen sozusagen
sehr geeignet werden damit sich das
virus dort länger hält aber wir müssen
da auf jeden fall berücksichtigen dass
viele faktoren für die stabilität eine
rolle spielen wie die temperatur die
sonneneinstrahlung insofern kann man da
das pauschal schwer beurteilen es könnte
sein wenn die bedingungen ideal sind das
ist auf holz auch sich länger hält oder
eben auf plastikmaterialien wir gehen
davon aus dass es in der realität
wahrscheinlich nur wenige minuten bis
vielleicht mal ein paar stunden sein
werden unter idealen bedingungen aber
länger nicht für zu hause und unterwegs
gilt dass flächen berührung etwa bei
türklinken immer eine konsequenz haben
sollten wenn man sie doch berührt und
eben gerade türklinken knöpfe die oft
angefasst werden dann sollte man sich
tunlichst nicht ins gesicht fassen
sondern danach eben die hände waschen
das vollkommen unproblematisch aber ganz
klar noch mal das risiko für eine
übertragung über tiere klinken oder
knöpfe ist sehr gering und ich kann es
eben noch weiter reduzieren indem ich
mir einfach regelmäßig die hände waschen
extremfall sollte man aber genauestens
auf
regeln achten wenn sie jetzt ein hoch
infektiösen kranken patienten haben der
wirklich krank ist und hustet und
sozusagen ordentlich in die hand husten
und dann die türklinke unmittelbar an
fest und sie unmittelbar danach die
türklinke anfassen und sich danach ins
gesicht das ist natürlich schon eine
erhöhtes risiko das muss man klar sagen
gerade in der familie sind die möglichen
übertragungswege besonders kurz und kaum
zu verhindern
ob nun im sanitärbereich oder beim essen
was will ihr essen wie will er es
natürlich kann man das auf ein minimum
zurückfahren und quasi wie ein astronaut
leben aber das ist nicht praktikabel
übertragungs wahrscheinlichkeit im
engsten familienkreis das lässt sich
dann kaum mehr vermeiden da müsste man
ja die kinder letztendlich wegschließen
oder dem papa längere zeit irgendwo ein
zimmer einsperren
das lässt sich nur bedingt mit großer
intensität durchhalten insofern sind da
einfach natürliche grenzen jonas schmidt
chanasit warnt aber auch davor es bei
der oberflächen frage zu übertreiben
etwa beim einkauf von lebensmitteln auch
unverpackten wenn sie eine gurke kaufen
und so weiter was nicht abgepackt ist
natürlich waschen sie das ab wie sieht
das sonst auch zu hause machen also
diese normalen maßnahmen sind vollkommen
ausreichen und sie müssen jetzt nicht
angst vor durch den supermarkt
schlendern und jede verpackung
abspringen dass wir vollkommen
übertrieben
wichtig ist da sind sich die experten
einig beim aufenthalt in geschlossenen
räumen bestimmte grundregeln zu beachten
lüften ist natürlich immer sehr ratsam
aber das betrifft eben hauptsächlich
auch die tröpfchen und eine mögliche
aerosol bildung weil natürlich wenn ein
luftstrom da es einfach letztendlich das
virus auch sich nicht so lange in der
luft halten kann
das ist auf jeden fall anzuraten
regelmäßiges durchlüften man sollte sich
ja so und so ihr im freien aufhalten
gerade wenn man sich eben mit jemanden
trifft oder mit zwei leuten trifft als
eben wirklich in engen geschlossenen
räumen und eines liegt dem hamburger
experten besonders am herzen um sich
selbst mit all diesen fragen rund um die
übertragungswege nicht völlig kirre zu
machen
bitte nicht übertreiben es muss ja
sozusagen wirklich dort passieren wo das
hauptrisiko ist dann verlieren wir auch
den fokus wenn wir uns auf diese sachen
konzentrieren auf türklinken auf
umverpackung oder irgendwas es geht um
den kontakt mit menschen das ist das
wichtigste und eben auf die eigene hände
hygiene zu achten sich verantwortlich zu
verhalten das scheint das wichtigste in
diesen zeiten sprich immer auch an den
oder die andere denken ihm oder ihr aber
nicht zu nahe zu kommen
ja so wie wir das hier auch im studio
versuchen professor dr bodo platter und
ich sie sind virologe an der uniklinik
in mainz wir haben fast den perfekten
abstand würde ich sagen
und sie haben weiter zeit normalerweise
sind sie da auch jetzt großem einsatz
aber sie sind hier um die fragen unserer
zuschauer zu beantworten und ich schlage
vor wir starten direkt mit der von
jürgen leib schutz der fragt wenn ein
infizierter mensch ein geldstück anfasst
also im grunde das thema was wir gerade
schon mal hatten
wie lange kann ich mich dann auch mit
dem virus infizieren oder auch
geldschein das frage ich mich immer wenn
ich bezahle irgendwo im prinzip genau
das gleiche was der kollege eben gesagt
hat es ist überall das gleiche
es kann natürlich auch oberflächen
überleben aber das ist sehr begrenzt sie
müsste schon auf den geldschein drauf
niesen quasi und dann weitergeben
und dann dann wirklich direkt ins
gesicht fassen und das passiert dieser
regel nicht aber klar auch da sollte man
darauf achten sich generell nicht so oft
ins gesicht zu fassen denn das ist
natürlich der weg auf dem solche viren
die auf oberflächen haften unter
umständen zelte selten mal übertragen
werden können ok der fokus liegt nach
wie vor auf der tröpfcheninfektion höre
ich da auch raus hans köck fragt kann
das virus an restaurantbesucher
übertragen werden wenn der koch
infiziert ist und zum beispiel salat mit
bloßen händen zubereitet
ja klar auch da gilt natürlich das
gleiche eigentlich gibt es keine
hinweise darauf dass tatsächlich über
nahrungsmittel diese viren wirklich
effizient in irgendeiner weise
übertragen werden
möchte natürlich auch irgendwo davon
ausgehen dass der kurs noch bevor so ein
salat wäscht vorher seine hände
gewaschen hat das kann man natürlich
nicht garantieren das ist richtig aber
auch wirklich es ist ein relativ
geringes risiko außerdem wäre sala
gewaschen insofern glaube ich das ist
sicherlich auch nicht der fokus auf
solchen übertragungswege sondern wie
sich auch sagen tatsächlich auf diese
tröpfchen entdeckt dann kommt irgendwann
auch in den magen klaus hillebrand
ähnliche frage mandarin schalen trauben
oder sonstiges obst also die magensäure
zerstört dann auch dem virus das ist
richtig so alles was wir bisher wissen
dass hält das virus nicht aus aber wir
bleiben kurz im restaurant mit der frage
von karin eickstädt die fragt nämlich
ich habe nicht verstanden was bringt das
restaurants um 18 uhr oder sogar schon
um 15 uhr zu schließen
können sie mir das erklären auch nicht
wirklich ganz genau aber es ist
wahrscheinlich dass nach 18 uhr das
sicherlich ein größerer besucher andrang
herrscht es ist ja offensichtlich
vorgegeben dass man sich reparieren
sollte in solchen restaurants und das
könnte natürlich dann zu schwierigkeiten
führen wenn dann ein großer ansturm ist
dann wird man nicht alle bedienen können
das könnte natürlich dann auch zu
unstimmigkeiten führen und bei der
vernunft an die wir ja immer gemeinsam
appellieren vor allerdings die experten
ist ein restaurantbesuch wahrscheinlich
ähnlich das was man jetzt auch ansonsten
nur jeden tag machen sollte genau fragen
die mir als kowski fragt wäre es nicht
sinnvoller allein die risikogruppen zu
isolieren als die gesamte bevölkerung
also das ganze im grunde umzudrehen ja
zunächst mal haben wir nicht die gesamte
bevölkerung augenblick isoliert sondern
es ist ja noch immer erhebliche freiraum
auch dass ich noch mal unterschiedliche
autobahn gegeben oder im studio
also das ist schon mal das eine und zum
anderen wie sollen wir die risikogruppen
wirklich definieren wenn man das sind
die älteren menschen sind auch menschen
mit grunderkrankungen
das lässt sich nicht genau eingrenzen so
dass das natürlich schwierig ist diese
menschen über längeren zeitraum hinweg
komplett von der anderen bevölkerung
abzutrennen das ist sicherlich sehr
schwierig also sind wir so wie es jetzt
läuft zumindest diesbezüglich auf dem
richtigen weg vielen dank dass sie hier
waren vielen dank für ihre zeit dass wir
uns fragen beantwortet haben professor
bodo platter
und unser corona kompakt liebe zuschauer
das finden sie auch online täglich neu
auf youtube und zwar auf dem kanal der
zdf heute außerdem können sie uns weiter
fragen an unsere experten schicken zum
beispiel brachte den sie gar noch mal
gesehen haben oder andere die versuchen
wir dann gemeinsam hier im studio zu
beantworten corona kompakte zdf ist die
e mail adresse dazu